let's talk a little bit about the why
like
why we probably should have started with
this like why is this something that
people should be
thinking about like why is this a better
way to go
weren't we born and bred to be omnivores
what's so
terrible about eating a moderate
and healthy omnivorous diet
yeah i think i mean a number of things
problematic
with that one is that that's a
diet lifestyle that contributes to
higher cases mortality across the board
a plant-based diet is
is as gregor says it you know should be
the default diet
until they're not proven otherwise
because it can reduce the risk of
all-cause mortality
for me it's you know i got into this
having
literally having dairy cows as as
friends
as pets as why do so many people in the
plant-based movement are
people who grew up on farms like dr
clapper there's something to that
because you look at animals differently
like how you would treat
your dogs we just extend that to
chickens because
think about this rich i mean i grew up
on a farm where you raise animals from
when they're babies
and if they're taken from their mothers
who's their new best friend it's you
i used to bottle feed baby calves before
getting on the school bus you know
like i used to hang out with baby chicks
and like you know play a little elevator
game with my hand like
they trust you like you are their you
know their person just like you
for your dog like you are that person so
i i think i just for me i just looked at
animals differently
and that was something that even if i
thought i might have
diminished returns on athletic success
adopting this lifestyle i was willing to
do it
because it just spoke to me and and
that's what's compelled me
all these years later for 25 years and
you know luckily it didn't
have a hindrance it didn't have any
adverse effects on my athletic
performance
in fact maybe helped it but that's
certainly one of the reasons
is is allowing animals to live
lives free of fear pain and suffering
and i think that's valid i think that's
worth considering we can talk about all
the environmental factors and i don't
even know
a lot of those nuances you know i'm not
a scientist i don't understand
all the greenhouse gas stuff i see the
quotes and how many
gallons of water it used to produce to
raise animals
and all of that and of course it's
important to me but i can't really speak
to that necessarily i can speak to
to my cause or my why
and i can speak to the fact that so many
people
even if it's anecdotal the stuff that
i've seen for 25
years people who are able to overcome
obesity
overcome illnesses become the best
versions of themselves
feel better than they've ever felt in
their lives because of a plant-based
diet
and i've also seen how people including
my family because both sides of my
family
come from farming backgrounds both
parents so aunts and uncles are all
farmers they still own you know
lots of acres and they farm and and and
they have
health problems that that those like
clapper and others who are the same age
bracket or older
don't don't have and again these are
just examples but they're but they're
close to home you know i i lost multiple
relatives recently
to diet related uh diseases
and that does hit close to home and
i know that a plant-based diet can help
with that because of forks over knives
and campbell and esselstyn and
barnard and copper and all those ornish
the legends in this game
and i think for people listening it's
it's worth giving it a shot because
the fear of for me at least and i know
you've experienced a little bit of this
in part of your journey the fear of
something like a heart attack or a
diet related disease that sneaks up on
me is you know that's kind of scary to
me and if i can reduce the risk of that
and live a long healthy life that's
that's worth it for me and still kill it
in the weight room yeah
the idea that you're not you don't have
to compromise that right
yeah and i think that's kind of what
this book has shown more than
more than like this is the trick to
becoming a great athlete like that's not
really what this is about it
it turns out that it is that for the
right person and there are lots of
people who
including all of us i think who kind of
experienced are
the most success we had athletically
once we went plant-based
uh but for me it's more that like you
can do this
and you can get all these great benefits
of the longevity really and health span
to me that's what it's all about i mean
i just think um
i you know you mentioned like the
omnivorous diet like what's wrong with
this
this is natural but natural doesn't
really
affect it doesn't really get into
healthy right nature selects for
reaching
reproductive age and a few years past to
raise your kids but
it's not really about what gets you to
80 90 and
keep moving and being healthy because
that doesn't matter for for
natural selection so to me that's like
where we should think about like not
like what is
and i don't honestly know what is the
most natural diet or whatever that even
means
uh but what's one is the data saying is
keeping people giving them the longest
health health span keeping them
mobile and happy and active and and
healthy and alive
and and it looks a lot to me like that's
the plant-based diet that that seems to
be where
the science is all pointing these days
right right
your your on-ramp uh robert was
ethics matt yours was more
health-related mine was
vanity vanity and health and athletic
performance ultimately
but what's so amazing and beautiful
about how this movement is blossomed
is that now there are all these on-ramps
from the ethical considerations of
course
to sustainability to climate change
concerns environmentally
sensitive you know which we all should
be of course
and the longevity health considerations
of the foods that we eat and now with
this book
plant-based athletic performance and i
think it's so
great because just like all the athletes
profiled in your book
different people connect with and and
resonate with
different individuals right so not
everybody is going to
cotton on to the ethical argument but
perhaps they're concerned about the
environment and
the way that i look at it as i look at
it as
this umbrella lifestyle that checks
every single box
like you can opt out of the chronic
lifestyle illnesses that are
unnecessarily killing
millions of people obesity rates right
now are through the roof
diabetes it's predicted something like
50 percent of americans are going to be
diabetic by 2030.
all of these chronic illnesses are
lifestyle illnesses directly correlated
to the foods that we're eating
meanwhile we're decimating the planet
because animal agriculture just requires
too many inputs too much land too many
resources
for us to sustainably produce enough
animal
products for the planet to eat as we you
know
careen down this path towards 10 billion
people living on this planet
but the fact that you know the truth is
most people
are walking around thinking about
themselves they're like that's fine
but like i just want to be buffed and i
want to eat what i want to eat and i
want to be able to kill it in the gym
or you know qualify for boston or
whatever it is and the truth is
is that all of those goals are not just
possible but
more possible by dent of learning what
you guys have laid out in this book
this you